يزرع رائد الفضاء ماد دايما البطاطا على
سطح الكوكب الاحمر يستخدم تربه وسمادا على
كوكب تي بيئه معاديه وقليله الموارد تحول
الخيال الى واقع بعد سنوات قليله من العرض
جهود ثمنها مليون دولار امريكي تقودها
وكاله ناسا لايجاد حلول مبتكره لمعضلات
الطعام خارج الارض فللحصول على الغذاء في
الفضاء لابد من صنع غذائي هناك في الفضاء
قائمه طعام الرواد محكمه بشروط معقده
ومليئه بالمحظورات لتشكل الخميره مكونا
اساسيا صالحا لتغذيه رواد الفضاء لالاف
السنين بحسب الخبراء فهي تحتوي على المواد
الغذائيه التي يحتاجها الانسان من الطعام
مثل البروتين والكربوهيدرات وباستخدامها
مع طابعه ثلاثيه الابعاد يمكن تخيل انتاج
ط مماثل للسوشي او اللازانيا وباستخدام
لون ورائحه معينه يمكن انتاج فاكهه الموز
كما انه تم استخدام الخميره المعدله جينيا
لانتاج الخبز والمعكرونه فيما يطور مختبر
في فلوريدا نظاما حيويا لتربيه الخضروات
الطازجه والفطر ويرقات الحشرات لاستخدامها
كمغذيات دقيقه بالاضافه لجهود زراعه الخس
والملفوف واللفت والفلفل الحار لتكون هذه
الاغذيه اكثر شهيه هذا النظام الغذائي لا
يترك نفايات في الفضاء ويعظم قدرات انتاج
الغذاء خارج الارض بحسب الخبراء يوما ما
يقول العلماء سيعيش البشر في اماكن بعيده
عن كوكبنا الام وستكون امامهم فرصه لبدايه
جديده تبدا ربما ب طعام جديد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات